well let's turn back to the NHS now in a
Health Service which seems to be an
ever-growing crisis as waiting times and
lists grow well before the usual winter
crisis nurses and ambulance staff will
walk out on strike this month and Junior
doctors will be balloted on action soon
that will be held by the British Medical
Association which is both the Trade
union and professional bodies for
doctors in the UK it's Council Deputy
chair Dr Emma runswick joins me now very
good to talk to you we just spoke to Wes
streeting their Shadow Health Minister
he says he's not afraid to take you on
he calls you vested interests and says
that you think he's a heretic for
wanting better patient access are you
concerned that you perhaps don't have as
good a relationship as you should with
the man who may well be Health secretary
very soon well certainly I'm
disappointed in the the rhetoric that
that Mr streeting is adopting you know
this is applying to charges that you've
made against him
well this this morning he's he's said in
the telegraph that NHS staff are looking
for for something for nothing and I
think I think my members and many health
staff across the UK will be absolutely
gobsmacked by that because we are giving
everything and receiving less than
nothing in return pay cuts real terms
pay cuts in return
and we agree that we want a Better
Health Service you know we're we're
working in it I see patients you know if
every week who have been waiting for a
long time to see us and it's really
devastating working in that that
situation where we know we're not
providing the standards of care that we
want to be the solution isn't to attack
the staff the solution is to attack the
government who are who are absolutely
responsible and for for driving our
service into the ground
uh as I say surely the the solution is
fixing this isn't it it's sitting down
talking about it and finding a solution
rather than attacking anybody do you
feel well absolutely you can talk to the
government this is between
um you know attacking and blaming NHS
staff and directing the blame where it
really is is deserved at the feet of the
government then then I think Mr Streeter
needs to needs to really focus on the
government who are responsible for the
for the problems we face
there have been dire warnings from all
parts of the NHS and and some of the
statistics that have been you know in
the news so much over the last few days
in all of your times working in the NHS
have you ever seen it this bad
no I think I think the honest answer is
no we haven't ever seen it this bad
we've got you know such extreme levels
of vacancy you know about 10 000 doctors
missing in Secretary care alone 47 000
nurses missing we've got 1 900 GPS fewer
than we did in in 2015 and provided more
appointments than ever so 32 million
appointments provided by those GPS this
year and yet we absolutely can't meet
the demand that we have on the service
um and that's a whole mixture of factors
but it means that we can't do as as well
as we would want to for patients and you
know we we hear all of the real patient
stories that underlines that misery for
us and it and it impacts on our mental
health and our well-being as well and
that's why so many are leaving one of
the reasons so many are leaving
if we want to fix those problems we
really have to tackle the issues of pay
pensions and working conditions that are
forcing staff out it's not just about
recruitment at the bottom end it's about
keeping the staff who are already in the
service and providing training to our
younger colleagues
do you think the NHS can cope this
winter
well the NHS is already collapsing and
has been for some some time now so are
we going to see you know worsening of
that collapse as demand increases this
winter and we have another covert wave
we have another flu wave we have and the
strep a both you know situation and the
Panic associated with it but are we
going to see worsening a worsening
situation I'm almost certain of that and
what can the government do things more
people will die
uh I do I do think more people will die
and I don't think
um you know this that's not something
that we that we want and there are some
solutions to that
um but the currently the government
won't even speak to us so we're in a
we're in a really difficult difficult
situation that none of us want to be in
as health workers we've all committed to
providing you know excellent patient
care we're aware that we're not able to
do that at the minute and we're doing
our best you know we're driving
ourselves into the ground trying to
provide that and we're working with each
other and increasingly we're organizing
to take a stand over our service and we
want our profession and you know for
doctors we want our profession to be
valued and and we want our skills across
the Health Service to be valued we want
the government and and patients from the
public to realize that we are trying but
also we're reaching the point where we
have to take action because if we don't
do anything it will keep getting worse
and you're balloting your members for a
pay rise for junior doctors
um what do you think the likelihood is
that they will go out on strike in the
new year
I think it's likely unless the
government is willing to negotiate with
us about pay so we're asking for a
reversal of a pay cut we've had you know
a pay cut for junior doctors of 26.1
since 2008 and so over a quarter of our
pay has been lost and this year again
we've received two percent pay award
which is about 10 less than inflation
that's another month working for free
I'll work in a whole month for free
compared to last year
currently won't even say sorry yeah
forgive me we haven't got a huge amount
of time but but what what number would
you like if you would if your dream
number that the government would give
you
but we're looking for pay restoration so
restoration of that pay cut yeah
absolutely but it's only a lot for the
government will give you a 25 pay rise
well it's it's only as steep as the
money that has been cut from us as only
as steep as the money that we've lost so
if the government as you know the
government has continued to give us
below inflation uh pay Awards year after
year no claps do not pay the bills you
know we are at a point now where we are
you know 10 000 doctors short in
secondary care alone
1900 fewer GPS than we've had in the
past we we really need to tackle the
problems of keeping staff in the service
and whether that's doctors nurses
ambulance staff you know paramedics
radiographers the whole team really need
to understand and to and to be valued by
the government and and therefore value
our patients and the service that we're
providing to them as well so to be clear
on this program you're saying you want a
25 pay increase
okay so if as inflation changes and we
will continue to seek restoration of the
losses that we've had okay
but you're saying that's 25 I mean as
you referred to the Goodwill that that
there was throughout covert and the
Clapping on the doorsteps many in the
country would love to see those in the
medical profession getting a pay rise
but you also said that you think people
will die partly as a result of the
strikes partly as a result of of the
state that the NHS is in over of this
winter do you think that there's going
to be a change are you worried that that
the public will perhaps not be quite as
much in love with the NHS after a few
weeks of strikes as they are now I think
that the public
um really understand
that our desire for investment in health
workers and the Health Service
is fundamentally about the wanting to be
able to provide and a really excellent
standard of care for patients that's
what it's about there's a there's an
absolute link between investment and the
Health Service and the quality of care
we're able to provide we all know that
we're we're not currently providing that
standard of care we want to be able to
do better
and therefore we are we are taking a
stand and asking the government to
invest in in us and the service that we
provide I think the public know that and
I think it's really clear to them you
know if if you don't trust doctors when
you're when you're asking this question
then ask the nurses if you don't trust
the nurses then ask the paramedics if
you don't ask you know trust the
paramedics and there's so many of us who
are now facing this this same set of
difficulties having faced such attacks
on our on our pay on our conditions and
on our service the service that we
provide to you over such a long period
of time there's so many of us now facing
these difficulties all of us have come
to the same conclusion and all of us are
looking for and for change and I think
that the public and patients will
understand that okay and just to be
clear you do think that it's very likely
a junior doctors will go and strike in
the new year
I do unless there is change from the
government you know it's in the
government
to negotiate and that was very clear
thank you very much Dr emerence with
Deputy chair of the BMA thank you very
much